hoy 27 de abril todos países vamos tiene
un color naranja la razón es la
conmemoración del llamado con el día del
reino que se celebra en el reino de los
países bajos en honor al cumpleaños del
rey willem alexander en esta oportunidad
luego de haber sido cancelados dos veces
por la pandemia no hay recepciones como
el uso obligatorio de tapabocas ni tanto
con distanciamiento social se lleva a
cabo el evento central aquí en la plaza
centrales de maastricht la ciudad
ubicada en el sur de los países bajos y
que es reconocida por su arquitectura
medieval escuchamos es de fondos tonadas
nórdicas tradicionales como parte de la
muestra musical adelantada para darle la
bienvenida al rey pero aunque en los
últimos ocho años esta tradición se ha
llevado a cabo en este día de abril
desde 2014 la realidad es que la idea de
ahorrar el natalicio del monarca de
turno data desde el año
1885 en el que el homenaje a la princesa
y posterior reina will emina fue
designado el 31 de agosto para celebrar
una festividad tan nacional en esta
fecha todos se reúnen en torno a la
familia y los amigos y brindan a la
salud del reino